foreign
Jessica
in San Antonio where they have the Alamo
which is where they have Peewee Herman's
basement what's up
hey how you doing good you
I'm doing all right I'm doing all right
excellent excellent usually all right is
code for not very great
well I don't think I'd be calling if I
was doing wonderful Fair well played
okay so what's up how can I help
hey okay so my question is
um should I marry my fiance
I don't know should you
well hold on all right before you even
tell me what's what's going on the fact
that you're calling me suggests that you
probably don't think you should be
crap right
kind of already yes I'm on that
I agree
this could be the fastest call in the
show history all right tell me what's up
tell me what's up okay so there's really
a lot to this but I'll try to make it
really short okay
um so we have currently been dating for
about two years
um off and on very tumultuous
um
he lived with me for a period of time
um during that time it was Rocky he
moved out got his own place no problem
great what is tumultuous and rocky mean
those are vague things that could mean
abuse it could mean infidelity it could
mean chaos stealing your money what does
that mean
um
well chaos
um on my end in his
um is
diagnosed uh
schizophrenic and he was not on
medications for a majority at the time
that he was staying with me
um what was your chaos related to
uh I have some
paranoid issues as well I was on
medicine for like paranoia depression
anxiety okay do either of y'all either
of y'all use
um so yeah that's what I'm getting to so
um no I do not no I do not currently I
do not do anything nothing smoke drink
nothing okay nothing whatsoever
um
now
I did in the past
um so I think that might have
contributed to my mental problem what
was your job of choice
well
um
preferably I would smoke marijuana but I
also did dabble in party drugs such as
like uh Molly I don't know if you're
familiar with that yes very very much so
yeah okay
um and I think that the Molly I really
think contributed to my my mental uh
paranoia uh yeah I can France yeah so
were you hallucinating were you seeing
stuff not saying things but very uh
paranoid as far as like oh this person's
following me
um
you know uh my boyfriend's cheating on
me
um just all of that okay um so here we
are you're engaged after all that you
look at each other and you say we should
get married
sounds genius
yo went to the IHOP and you were like
you're the one right over the table all
right so you're engaged now
mm-hmm
so um he he's living on his own
um
he said you know okay we're engaged I
want to come clean
um
usually you come clean before but right
hey you know what here we are they're
here we're here right we're here right
good um he says I want to come clean I I
use meth okay I said okay
um I said that makes a lot of sense
um and he said no it was just one time I
used it when I moved out of your
apartment when I was moving my stuff out
um that was the only time
however before he moved out
um I did go through his phone
um and I found some messages from him to
an unregistered number in his phone
asking for a 20. a small amount asking
for a small amount and I had confronted
him about it and I said what's up are
you are you using drugs no you said no
I'm not I was getting him for somebody
else okay and it made sense to me
how could that possibly have made sense
to you because he has a very um
self-righteous attitude towards like my
family and my family's addiction problem
um he would talk negatively about
um office the most the most
if you want to know what somebody is
truly dealing with
like deep behind all their masks and
their their seven layers of skin
you want to know what somebody's really
struggling with
find out what they're self-righteous
about
because that's what that's that's where
that's where the dragon sits to cover up
that wound inside someone's obsessed
with your sexual activity or they're
struggling someone's obsessed with I
can't believe addicts are man they are
you know what I'm saying so I I but I
get it so
you think he's been using meth all along
there's some there's some real real some
some significant overlap and
similarities in
um symptomology right in in the way that
someone who's mapped out or someone
who's struggling with schizophrenia
um presents to the world right very very
similar overlaps
right exactly and that and then that's
another reason why
like the you know the symptoms that I
saw that I could you know that I
would have just attributed to a drug
problem I you know knowing his diagnosis
attributed to just his mental
disorder gotcha
um and let's let's be clear he may have
full-blown schizophrenia if he does meth
is not helping that problem
right right and or he might not have
schizophrenia at all he might
um just right be messed up and seeing
things or experiencing things and
um have an un unclear understanding of
reality
um yeah
so here's Here's my thought the bigger
problem is not that he's used drugs okay
I'm never going to tell somebody you
should never marry somebody just because
of things they've done their past I
think that's a shallow laneway to look
at the world but
I do think there are some things to be
cautious of and I am much more concerned
um
that there's deceit there's dishonesty
here
um
there is hiding and sneaking he's
sneaking around you you're going through
his phone without telling him he's doing
this he's I I just the whole thing feels
really it feels like you are going to an
amusement park and you're signing up for
the ride that ends in a train wreck
that's what it feels like
I I agree
but I will never ever ever tell you
unless there is
um abject abuse to not get married
that's a choice you have to make
right and if any anybody who knows me
knows that I will do what I want that is
I mean that's that's just uh then let me
take him out of the room you are not
ready to get married
because I I'm serious because marriage
is you walking to somebody else this
whole nonsense look dude I I'm convinced
with all my guts the last 25 or 30 years
all of the marriage advice if you will
if you want to call it that was you have
to be a hundred percent whole
before you can marry somebody and what
we have now is an entire generation of
married individuals who are cohabitating
their homes or co-managing their
marriages or co-managing their children
they're co-managing their houses
and they are no more they're just
glorified roommates who hook up less and
less and less and less
and so as as crazy as this sounds the
idea that like I'm just gonna get what I
want then do don't get married because
that's not marriage marriage is taking a
knee and saying I will dedicate my life
to making sure you're you're elevated
and hopefully you marry somebody who has
that same sentiment and you both spend
your lives bringing each other up
right so yeah dude you're not right
you're not ready to get married
you know don't do it and if I'm not
uh if I don't agree with that statement
then I'm I probably still would do it
even though I know it's a train wreck
waiting to happen oh so if somebody says
hey not that I would be not that I
wouldn't be give myself to him
fully and want the best for him and you
know his needs and things like that but
I'm just saying like as far as like if
someone's were to tell me no don't do it
I probably even if I know it's going to
end badly probably so like practically
speaking stepping back
I would want to see
um if you're my if you're my best buddy
you're my sister I would want to see a
you two go to some pre-marital
counseling that includes total
truth-telling
I would want to see a mutual commitment
to sobriety and that's not just like
yeah that means that we're going to go
to both of us are going to go to
meetings every day for the next 60 days
I want to see a mutual commitment to
going after a period of 60 days of
getting sober going back to a
psychiatrist getting another
um mental health eval and then if I do
have schizophrenia or if I have damaged
myself it's like a lot neurologically
through my drug use and I now need
support and resources to be able to be a
functioning member of society which is
great there's no problem in that
um then I'm gonna get the meds that I
need I I would want to see we are
entering into this thing both of us with
a plan on how we can best be whole and
show up for one another
right
and based on what you've told me that is
a tall order
well actually no marriage counseling was
in the uh plans as far as
um but marriage counseling you can't
just go and talk about stuff you have to
go set out a plan and then that the
execution of that plan
is going to be is going to be the
indicator that says yes we are both
we're both on a healing journey together
and we're going to do this
I think you can here's my bigger
question less about does somebody use
meth more about what is so
devastating inside the body of somebody
that is using math
that this is helping them get through
their day
because because dude alcohol weed those
things work
that's that's the deal they work cooking
works
it helps pull your body away from trauma
from pain from hurting
and it disassociates you from yourself
and everybody else it kills you over
time
and so the question is not why are you
using drugs the question is
what is going on inside of you that this
is the best way your body's figured out
how to cope
that's what we're gonna unwind in rehab
that's what we're going to unwind in AAA
is we're gonna unwind with a mental
health professional and
then when we get all the trains back on
the tracks then we're talking hey let's
start making long-term plans together
um and man I think you walk alongside
each other in this you clearly love this
guy and um he loves you
I think I'll make a plan to walk
together but
here's the deal if you get married next
weekend I'll cheer you on I'll want the
best for you I'll want it all to work
out super super great I will never root
against you uh but if you're my friend
or my sister I would say hey let's let's
slow the roll a little bit and uh let's
come up with a better plan
I wish you guys the best Jessica thank
you for your call